ian e aí galera que está escrito eu mato
vocês evitado é esse dia eu estava
conversando com meu colega ea gente
começou a falar sobre infância já tinha
feito um vídeo sobre infância mas não
quero fazer outro programa eu faço eu
quiser essa [ __ ] parar pra pensar que a
infância é o momento que você mais
guarda lembranças boas na sua vida
porque a infância aumento da sua vida em
que até o momento ruim vira motivo de
alegria depois que você cresce você tá
com essa que são amigas espaço hoteleiro
e pelo visto cair de bicicleta quebrou o
braço vez por muito mais velho de quebra
o braço e acho engraçado mas depois é
isso que eu acho mais mágico da infância
você poder pegar os momentos ruins de
antigamente e ri depois das coisas que
eu gostava mais quando era criança era
brilho porque quando você é criança se
você vai brigar é ruim se você é uma das
duas pessoas que está brigando é muito
ruim mas se você é uma daquelas pessoas
que joga lenha na fogueira é muito
chover e eu era assessor de jogar lenha
na fogueira daquelas crianças que a
gente gosta de chamar de menino do cam
sabe que as crianças que tiver alguma
coisa o pé passa e derruba só para fazer
o mal pois ganho a ouvir aqueles minha
começar a brigar eu começar a jogar
lenha na fogueira
ficava senhora me rodando acioli rodando
é chegar perde e falar se vestir e
shitake encarando a eu dizia assim até
macaco é outro responde tomando com a
vitamina como tuitou exprime a outra
responde tomando cunha lima como turismo
é outra responde dia tomando como
borboleta como tal pelo pizza que é bom
falar não nessa que é muito pesado tem
criança assistir era muito chuvas brilho
e briga de criança é muito mais
interessante que o diabo que bridge
adulto quando o produto começa a brigar
por ele chega pede meta um tapa na cara
sem contar que hoje em dia o moleque
roupa a escola leva o canivete a arma
facão motossera o leque para de cabo e o
cara resolve longa parada alimento para
até louco mas diretamente não quando era
criança moleque não é o meu suficiente
se ele não chegasse a mãe do outro e eu
comendo qualquer votavam lenha na
fogueira chegava lá e fazia assim essa
que a mãe dele esta que a mãe dele aí
faz o que eu quero fazer assim lhe bateu
na mãe
mateus
a mãe não vai fazer nada a outra imagem
assim vi cuspiu na mãe é eu deixava eu
deixava e se eu não deixava bastante com
a cabeça da pessoa humana e começava a
rolar no chão
brigando e que amo e o possibilita mas o
melhor o melhor disso tudo é que depois
do levantador não dava meia hora tá
brincando ippf juntar jogando bola no
mesmo quintal emprestando caneta bic por
saber que devolver mais alto na paz não
é é isso que eu gosto da infância é isso
que eu gosto de brincar de branco o show
de vocês em criança é isso é você poder
pegar essas experiências ruins
transformados em coisas legais é às
vezes quando era criança gostava de
acordar cedo pra não fazer nada não sei
se já aconteceu com você só você pode
você fica na feita só com você acorda
você fica na frente da televisão sem
saber o que está assistindo sério eu
acordava para assistir telecurso 2000 só
porque eu gostava de escutar o cara
falando assim a atenção agora é hora da
revisão não assistiu o bondinho
companhia conteúdo é preciso ainda eram
pequenos
quer ter com a priscila ainda era
pequena porque o rio continua pequeno
não liguei para lá porque eu sabia que
eu nunca ganhei nada 400 28 922 novo som
do japonês que veio pra lascar você está
falando isso porque houve euforia
domingo gritando place pede-se o
playstation playstation eye no final
ninguém a desgraça de um jogo da vida
por isso hoje lembro da minha infância
que sempre me lembra coisa boa então se
você está no facebook por favor curtis a
postagem compartilhar com alguém que
você queira que lembra da infância você
está aqui no youtube clique em adicionar
depois clique em favoritos isso ajuda
muito se você gostou deste vídeo não se
esqueça de clicar em gostei porque isso
ajuda muito para que eu continue fazendo
vídeos sabe que não faço um vídeo e
depois eu vou lá e tem de ser lá 5.000
gostei eu fico muito feliz cara dá
vontade de fazer um vídeo novo na mesma
hora eu quero que você comente aqui
embaixo aquilo que você mais gostou na
sua infância não se esquece de mim
assinar no facebook de me seguir no
twitter e de me seguir aqui no instagram
se você ainda não está inscrito neste
canal é só clicar aqui embaixo inscrever
se ou aqui em cima
prevê se eu não sei mais o que é que é
mas hoje você vê inscrever clique lá e
aí toda vez que tiver um vídeo novo você
vai saber
muito obrigado porque assisti até aqui
valeu